ก็
สวัสดีค่ะคุณฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงหูแล้วก็
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
เยยกับคู่ฟ้าและครูหญิงนะคะ
นักช่องคอมพลีเมน Fever ไทยใช่มั้ยร้อง
กับระดับดีกินเนอะแม่นะคะใช่เลยเราก็สบาย
ดีไหมคะผู้หญิงวันนี้สบายดีค่ะแข็งแรงคิด
ว่า
ยังมีไม่ถึงไม่มี
ครูขาโต๊ะสบายดี 5 เจ็บคอ
เจ็บคอนิดหน่อยโอเค
ไปก็ยังว่าทำไมเอาเนาะยังไม่มีโควิชหาเธอ
ไม่มีไม่มีแล้วก็ไม่มีวัคซีนด้วยโป้
นักเรียนก็คงจะแบบ
ส่งสัยให้เค้าว่าทำไมประเทศไทยไม่มี
วัคซีน
กุมภาก็ส่งกันใช้ค่ะไม่ใช่แค่นักเรียนเรา
สองคนก็ส่งสัยทำไมน่า
สงสัยใช่ไหมเวลาที่เราส่งสัยก็คือเราแบบ
เราอยากรู้
จะต้องมี
มีอะไรกูครับ
ใช่
เราก็ต้องมีเครื่องหมายคำถามใช่แบบ
ทำไม
ทำเหมือน
ใช้เหมือนเวลาที่นักเรียนเนี่ยดูวีดีโอ
ของเราหรือว่าเงียบไทยฟังภาษาไทยไปบาง
ครั้งนักเรียนก็อาจจะส่งสัย
สงสัยครูพูดภาษาไทยนักเรียนก็สงสัยมีนิ่ง
อะไรไม่ใช่มั้ยถ่ายหรือยิ่งถ้านักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยแล้วก็เห็นขวดไทยเห็นนเห็นๆว่า
จะสงสัยมากกว่า
ขอเพราะว่าประเทศไทยกับประเทศนักเรียนไม่
เหมือนกัน
ใช่ห่า
มีเรื่องให้สงสัยเยอะมากเลยใช้เหมือนผู้
หญิงเนี่ยผู้หญิงเคยไปอเมริกาแล้วก็ 1
ครั้งหน้านะคะครูฟ้าไปกินพิซซ่า
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็มีพิซซ่าใช่ไหมคะใช่หะ
อธิษฐานต้าทรายพิซซ่าที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ย
เวลานักเรียนไปกินพิซซ่าที่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยค่ะก็จะมีซอสมะเขือเทศเห็นเนาะสอศ.
มะเขือเทศใช่แล้วหลังมีอะไรนะคะ
ออริกาโน่หรอ
อะไร
เวลาคุณไปนั่งที่ร้านสมัยมีโต๊ะน้อง
โต๊ะ
เวลาไปกินพิซซ่าใช่ไหมคะมันก็จะรินโต๊ะ
เป็นโต๊ะ
แล้วก็นี้ก็จะมีเก้าอี้
ให้เข้าอีกอันนี้โต๊ะมีเก้าอี้แล้วก็บน
โต๊ะก็จะมีอ่ะซอสมะเขือเทศ
ซอสมะเขือเทศแล้วก็มีออริกาโนอันนี้ตี
ประเทศไทยธรรมดาแต่ตอนไปอเมริกาแล้วก็ไป
ร้าน pizza
เป็นบนเนี่ยไม่มีซอสมะเขือเทศไม่มี We
Are แล้วอะริกาโน่อ่ะมีออริกาโนอันนี้ก็
เข้าใจมีแล้วก็มีนี่ด้วยภูฟ้าอะไรคะพีสมี
พาเมซานชีสเอาไว้โรย pizza ใช่ๆ
อันนี้โอเคเพราะว่า Pizza มี Cheese
แป้งอะไรคะ 1 ครูฟ้ามันคือมันมีพริก
เห็นไหมติ๊ก
ต้นต้องเป็นบิวตี้บล็อกเกอร์และ
มีพริ้งบ่นอ่ะคลิกเผ็ดเขตที่คนไทยใส่
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว 5 มีอยู่บนโต๊ะ
มีพริกคริงแบบ
สงสัย
ทำไมกินพิซซ่าใช่อ่ะคะแล้วใส่พริก
คนไทยกินพิซซ่าใส่พริกไหมคะ
อ่าพิซซ่าคอมปะนีนะแล้วแต่เราไม่ใช่ไง
ปกติบางครั้งนี้ไม่ค่อยมีไงอ่ะใส่ใต้อัน
นี้มันไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ Pizza  Company นะไม่
ใช่ผู้หญิงอ่ะง่วงลูกตอนนั้นใหญ่คิดว่า
ไม่เคยไปอาจจะไม่เคยไปเห็นใน Pizza
Company ก็ได้หรือว่าไม่เคยดูไม่เคยมอง
ไม่พอไปแล้วก็มียีสต์บริการโอ้พริกป่น
ทำไมบนโต๊ะร้าน pizza มีพริกป่นส่งสัยไง
สงสัยคนอเมริกากินพิซซ่าใส่พริกรัฐ Heart
7 เขตหรือเปล่าๆขายส่งแอร์ค่าเรียนบ้าน
ประเทศไทยกินพิซซ่านักเรียนจะจัดสงสัย
สงสัยอะไรคะสงสัยว่าทำไมคนไทยกินพิซซ่า
ใส่ซอสมะเขือเทศ
นั่นสิบิ๊กสิทธิ์
ลูกค้าเนี่ยเวลากินพิซซ่าเนี่ยต้องมีซอส
มะเขือเทศทุกครั้งเลยครับได้ได้เวลาคน
อเมริกาคนฝรั่งคนยุโรปเนี่ยเห็นซอสมะเขือ
เทศกับพิซซ่าเขาก็สงสัยใช่ไหมทำไมทำไมคน
อื่น
เพราะอะไรเพราะอะไรก็มีซ้อนคนไทยกินน่ะ
กินพิซซ่าซอสสปาเก็ตตี้ก็ต้องมีซอสมะเขือ
เทศ
บีบใส่สปาเก็ตตี้หญิงสลายแต่พอนักเรียน
อยู่ประเทศไทยมีการก็อ่อนเข้าใจสมัยไม่
สงสัยแล้วหายคนไทยฉีกซอสมะเขือเทศแล้วก็
บีบใส่พิซซ่าแล้วก็
อร่อย
เรียนสงสัยใช่ไหมคะฮ่าๆจะทำไฟฟ้าเคยสงสัย
อะไรไหมเวลาเด็กๆก็โตแล้ว
กูฟ้าเคยสงสัยว่า
น้ำส้มจะยากไปไหมได้ๆน้ำส้ม
น้องส้มสายชูอ้ะนะนักเรียนแล้วเปิดให้ดู
น้ำส้มสายชูใส่ shoes  are
True ฟ้าสงสัยหรอเกี่ยวกับน้ำส้มสายชู
ให้อ่ะ
คะเปรี้ยวใช่ไหมรสเปรี้ยวทั้งต้องใส่ชู
ทำไม
ถึงเป็นสีเหมือนน้ำน้ำเปล่า
ทำไมน้ำส้มสายชูเป็นสีใสๆใช่ไหมฉี่เขาใคร
ใสๆแบบเนี้ยๆไหมมันเหมือนเอาน้ำปูปลาหาย
ให้เหมือนน้ำเปล่าใช้เวลานักเรียนดื่ม
หรือเปล่าเวลานักเรียนดื่มน้ำเปล่าน้ำแร่
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยหิมะสีมันจะเป็นแบบนี้อ่ะ
ใส่หนึ่งแล้วก็น้ำเปล่าเนี่ย
น้ำเปล่า
สักครู่นะฮะค่ะน้ำสะอาดนะนักเรียน
มันก็เป็นสีใสๆเหมือนกัน
ขอ
ตอนครูฟ้าเห็นน้ำส้มใส่ชูวิทย์มีน้ำเปล่า
ใช้ตอนภูฟ้าเด็กๆทั่วฟ้าสงสัยสงสัยทำไม
น้ำส้มสายชูน้ำเปล่าเหมือนกัน
[เพลง]
อ้วนมาฝากมันไม่มันไม่ใช่มั้ยฮะ
แล้วกูเคยถามคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไหมเวลากูฟ้า
สงสัยเราถามคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไหมทำไมมันเหมือน
กัน
เอ่อกูพักก็ถามคุณพ่อนะคะ
คุณพ่อก็บอกไม่รู้
ว่าแล้วก็เลยจะพูดเลยคุณพ่อก็สงสัยเหมือน
กันลูกค้าถามพ่อทำไมน้ำส้มสายชูกับน้ำ
เปล่า
ดูแล้วเหมือนกันเลยบ้านสงสัยเนี่ยสงสัย
คุณพ่อก็บอกว่าพ่อก็สงสัยเหมือนกันนะ
โอ้โหไม่รู้
ก็ต้องสงสัยเหมือนป๊า
ก็คือไม่รู้ตอนนี้ก็อยากนอนนี้ครูฟ้าก็
ยังไม่รู้ยังสงสัยอยู่จนถึงทุกวันนี้
สงสัยอยู่ไม่รู้เลย
จ่ายแต่ถ้าเคยได้ยินสมัยบางครั้งอ่ะนัก
เรียน 5 คนฝรั่งคนจีนคนเกาหลีใช่มั้ยมา
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยหรือกรุงเทพฯบางครั้งเข้า
มากรุงเทพฯเขาเห็นใช่ไหมเห็นมากๆเนี่ยนัก
เรียนหลายๆคนเนี่ยก็เคยสงสัยหนึ่งอย่าง
จึงมีเยอะๆนะแต่ 1 ยังผู้หญิงจำได้
คืออะไรอ่ะผู้หญิงเกี่ยวกับรถแท็กซี่
ทำไมอ่ะจริงๆประเทศนักเรียนมีดีแทคซี่
ประเทศไทยแต่นักเรียนเขาสงสัยว่าทำไม
แท็กซี่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีขายหลายสิงห์อ่ะ
มีหางสีแดงสมัยแท็กซี่สีแดงแท็กซี่สี
เหลือง
ทำไมแท็กซี่สีเหลือง
สีชมพู
นกสีฟ้ากูชมพู
ฟ้าสีส้ม
เขียวเหลือง
lembu อ้ะ
นักเรียนเขาก็สงสัยใช่ไหมว่าทำไมหรอมัน
ไม่เหมือนกันหรอ
นั่นสิแบบทำไมแท็กซี่ถึงมีหลายๆสี
แล้วผู้หญิงบอกไปว่ายังไงคะผู้หญิงก็บอก
ว่า
ไม่รู้
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ถ้าเป็นเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยมัน
อยากได้ใช่ไหมถ้าแช็คซี่สีเขียวสีเหลือง
ผมขอฟาร์มเปิดให้ดูหน่อยได้ไหมคะแท็กซี่
สีเขียวสีเหลืองเนี่ยจะเป็นแท็กซี่แบบ
เขียวเหลืองเมื่อก่อนนะเมื่อก่อนนะตอนนี้
กูหญิงไม่แน่ใจแต่ถ้าเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยคนไทย
จะเข้าใจแท็กซี่เขียวเหลืองเป็น Private
เป็นใครเราอ่ะแต่ถ้าแอ๊คซี่สีอื่นก็คือมี
บริษัทบริษัทบริษัทไม่เหมือนกันไม่ค่อย
สนิทกะฟ้าแท็กซี่ก็แท็กซี่สีส้มหญิง
แท็กซี่แท็กซี่สีน้ำเงิน a  Taxi แท็กซี่
สีชมพู
ไม่เหมือนเจ้าของไม่เหมือนกันแท็กซี่สี
ไม่เหมือนกันอ๋อ
นักเรียนก็เข้าใจใช่ไหมคะไม่เล่นก็
เข้าใจมาอีกสงสัยแล้วไปส่งทรายอ่ะ
แต่จริงๆเนี่ยอะไรคะกูขาก็มีเรื่องพี่ครู
ฟ้าสงสัยเหมือนกันอะไรอ่ะสงสัยอะไรครูฟ้า
อยู่กับมาม่า
พรุ่งนี้วันนี้ยังสงสัยล่ะสงสัยอะไร
อันนี่อาจจะรู้จักมาม่าต้มยำกุ้งใช่ไหมคะ
ค่ะนอาม่าก็คือแบบเป็นคัพนู้ดเดิ้ลเอาะ
ประเทศไทยไม่เป็นครับก็มีนะคะเป็นห่อ
เดี๋ยวต้องนะมาม่าต้มยำกุ้ง
ชั้นนี้อร่อยนะ
เฮ้ยลูกค้าสงสัยอะไรเกี่ยวกับมาม่า
ถ้าสงสัยว่าเวลาครูฟ้าหิวเออ
โอ๊ยหิวจังกินอะไร
กินมาม่าอ่ะฟ้าก็หยิบมาม่าอันเนี้ยมัน 1
มีสิ่ง
แล้วเวลากินเนี่ย
มันก็ยังไม่อิ่มค่ะ
แล้วฟ้าก็เลย
หยิบมาม่านี้มาอีก 1 ห่อเป็นห่วงค่ะแล้ว
ก็กินก็กินได้นิดหน่อยว่าอิ่มแล้ว
คือมัน
จะสงสัยว่าทำไม 1 หอมันไม่อิ่มแต่ 2 ห่อ
ก็กินไม่หมดกินไม่หมดกับออยอิ่มยังมาม่า
ยังเต็มเลยกินไม่หมดเลยหละมันก็จะมีนี้หา
นักเรียนเข้าเป็นมาม่าต้มยำกุ้งเนี่ยคือ
เขาก็เห็นแล้วใช่ไหมว่าห่าคนไทยเนี่ยกิน
มาม่า 1 ห่อไม่อิ่มอ่ากิน 2 ห่อถ้ากินไม่
หมดไม่ติดมากเขาก็เลยทำเป็นนี่เลยอะไรคะ
มาม่าบิ๊กแพ็ค
ก็คือใหญ่กว่า 1 ห่อปกติแต่ไม่ถึง 2 ห่อ
เหรอให้หาใหญ่กว่า 1 หอมอันบิ๊กขึ้นมานิด
นึงอ่ะเออกูฟังเลยกินไหมถ้ากินก็แบบ
มีมาม่าบิ๊กแพ็คภูเขาก็จะได้กินมาม่าแบบ
อิ่มพอดีพอดี
ก็ไปซื้อมาแล้วก็หยิบบิ๊กแพ็คมากินเออ
ออกซ้ายกินหอยเนี่ยอ่ะบ่
ถิ่มนะเออแต่ไม่อร่อย
ไม่อร่อยจริงอร่อยเหมือนหอปกติหรอกุกคือ
จะพูดยังไงอ่ะถ้าเป็นมาม่าแบบอย่างเงี้ย
ถอดเล็กๆน่ะแม่อร่อย
แต่ถ้าเกิดเป็นมาม่า
บิ๊กแพ็คอย่างเงี้ย
ไม่อร่อย
คู่ฟ้าสงสัยมาสักพักนึงและว่ากูมันเพราะ
อะไรนะฮะทำไมมันไว้อร่อยๆห่าละอยู่ถ้า
เป็นมามากครับ
อ้าวช้อปปี้ทำไมเค้าเนี่ยมาม่าเส้นสด
เป็นยังไงอันนี้คืออร่อยที่สุดเลย
แต่มันเป็นมาม่าเหมือนกันนะค่ะเหมือนกัน
เอ้อใช่มั้ยต้มยำกุ้งแบบมาม่าครับอย่าง
เงี้ยหรือว่าแบบต้มยำกุ้งแบบอ่า
เออหรือว่าแบบบิ๊กแพ็ค
มันก็เป็นต้มยำกุ้งเหมือนกันน่ะ
แต่ทำไมวันอร่อยไม่เท่ากัน
สงสัยใช่ไหมกูว่าสงสัยมานานแล้วอ่ะแล้ว
เวลาคุณฟ้าจะกินมาม่า
ก็ต้องกินมาม่าอะไรดีกินมาม่าครับ
มาม่าปกติหรือมากๆบิ๊กแฮกกินอะไรดี 1
สงสัยตอนนี้รู้หรือยังคะยังถ้ายังไม่รู้
เลยตอนนี้ก็ยังไม่รู้ว่าทำไมไม่รู้ว่า
ทำไมบิ๊กแพ็คถึงไม่อร่อยมากๆปกติถึงอร่อย
กว่าหรือมามากครับอร่อยที่สุดฟ้ายังไม่
ค่อยจะ
ฟ้าเคยเขาบอกว่าเด็กยุคนี้เนี่ย 2,000  21
เนี่ยมันมีเทคโนโลยีเวลาที่เราสงสัยอะไร
ก่อนใช่ไหมตอนครูฟ้าเด็กๆครูฟ้าสงสัยก็
ต้องถามคุณพ่อคุณแม่หรือว่าไปโรงเรียนถาม
ครูแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยไม่ต้องทำอะไรอ่ะถาม
กูเกิลเอาถาม Google แต่ Google ไม่รู้
ทั้งหมดนะ
ไม่เคยเข้าไปเสิร์ชหานะก็ไปเจอเว็บไซต์
พันทิปค่ะแล้วก็มีคนสงสัยเหมือนครูฟ้าปิง
เลยอ๋อยังไม่มีคำตอบเลยเนาะจัดตอนนี้ก็
ยังไม่รู้กูเกิลก็ไม่มีใครตอบได้ว่าไม่
รู้เหมือนกันทำไมมาบ้ามันอร่อยไม่เข้ากัน
ไอ้ท่าขี้มันเป็นมาม่าต้มยำกุ้งนะมึง
เหมือนกันเลยทั้งคับปกติบิ๊กแพ็คเนี้ย
ไม่ถึงก็ไม่รู้ว่ากูหญิงก็ไม่ไม่เคยกิน
มาม่าบิ๊กแพ็ค
on เคยกินมามากปกติกับคำนี้เดิิน
ถ้าเกิดนักเรียนอยากรู้นะคะชั้นเรียนไป
เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่นหรือว่าไปช็อปปิ้งมอลล์นะ
คะแล้วก็ลองไปซื้อมาม่าไว้แล้วก็เช็คดู
ว่าคิดถึงไม่อร่อยมันอร่อยไม่เท่ากันใช่
วันที่ครูฟ้าบอกไหม
หรือฆ่าหรือถ้านักเรียนรู้ว่าทำไมมัน
อร่อยไม่เท่ากันก็คอมเม้นท์บอกครูฟ้าได้
ถ่ายคู่พระจะได้ไม่สงสัยแล้วนะคะตอนนี้กู
ข้ายังสงสัยอยู่
ทำไมอ่ะใหม่และครูฟ้าก็ยังไม่ได้คำตอบว่า
ต้องทำ
ฮะ
โอเคค่ะแล้วก็ถ้านักเรียนสงสัยอะไรหรือ
ว่าเคยสงสัยอะไรทำไมสงสัยอะไรเกี่ยวกับ
ประเทศไทย
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เหมือนเดิมได้เลยค่ะ
เอาใจก็เราต้องไปแล้วนะคะใช้เห็ดกิน like
กด Share กด Subscribe เพื่อนะคะนักเรียน
สายค่ะแล้วก็มาเจอกับเราในวีดีโอหน้า
จะดีโอนี้ก็กำลังสงสัยและครูซ้าเป็นอะไร
ทำไมค่ะ
ผิดหรือเปล่า
ด็อกเตอร์นี้เราสองคนไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันนะ
คะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีฮะค่ะอ่ะ